today bring you the latest on
our vaccination program and our work to
get
even more people protected from this
deadly
disease we've come a long way
since we gave the world's first
clinically authorized vaccine
just over six months ago since that very
special
day we've now given a first dose
to 82 percent of all adults
in the united kingdom and today
i can confirm we've reached the
milestone of
three in five three and five of all
adults
getting the protection of a second dose
because we've been able to move at such
a pace
any adult in the uk can now book
their first dose in the two days
after we opened our booking system to
anyone over the age of 18
there were six appointments being booked
every second and i've been
absolutely thrilled to see videos of
young people
coming forward at some of our major
vaccination events
last weekend and i'm sure they'll be
doing the same this coming
weekend the enthusiasm
is making a huge difference
we've already given first doses
to almost half of all 25
to 29 year olds in england
and only a week after the program
opened to all adults
on friday one-third one-third
of people aged between 18 and 24
have had their first dose to all of the
young people
who have stepped up i want to say a huge
thank you
you've protected yourself you've
protected your families
and you've protected your communities
because the one thing you know we know
is the vaccines are making the real
difference the vaccines are
our way out of this pandemic the latest
data
show that the vaccination program has
already saved over 14
000 lives and i can share with you
that now it has prevented over 44
500 44 thousand five hundred
hospitalizations
in england alone that's two and a half
thousand
hospitalizations prevented in the past
two weeks and when you look into the
makeup
of hospital admissions you can clearly
see
our vaccination program is working
can i have the first slide please in
january
people over 65 made up the vast
majority of hospital admissions
that is why we vaccinated them early
in the program if you look at the most
recent data
they show that now they make up less
than a
third so when we look at the
uh protection that the vaccines
deliver it is clear from that slide
that it's clean extremely effective
especially with two days
against the delta variant the recently
published
uh data from public health england
looked at around
500 hospital admissions with the delta
variant
of these admissions 324
patients so over 60 percent were
unvaccinated
87 had received only one dose
of a vaccine and 40 had received two
doses
so fewer than one in ten people in
hospital
with the delta variant had received two
doses
this really does show the importance of
getting the jab and critically
getting that second dose so our mission
is now to get as many people protected
as we can and to protect them
as quickly as we can last week
we took the difficult but i think
essential decision
to pause step four in our roadmap for
four weeks
with a review of the data after two
weeks and we will absolutely
have that review and share the data with
the nation
we're going to use these four weeks to
give our nhs
that bit more time so that we can get
those remaining jabs
in arms of those who really do
need them so let me give you an example
of why it is so
important two weeks ago there were over
two million
two million people over the age of 50
in england who'd had a first dose but
not their second dose now
that number two weeks later is nine
hundred thousand
down from two million to nine hundred
thousand this pause
has and saved thousands of lives
and will continue to do so by allowing
us
to get more of the second doses
into arms of those most vulnerable to
covert before the restrictions are eased
further we've also reduced the interval
from first to second jab for over 40s
to eight weeks and i would urge everyone
watching
if you are over 40 come forward
and have your second jab take the
opportunity
and get the second jab early you can do
that
by going online at the national booking
service or calling one one
night we've seen phenomenal uptake
and enthusiasm for our vaccination
program so far the united kingdom has
won
the highest rates of vaccine confidence
in the world
nine in ten people nine and ten of all
adults say they've either taken the
vaccine
or that they want to take the vaccine
it's something we can all be proud of
but it is no
accident ladies and gentlemen
we got here because
we have actively
and nikki will be very much
explaining exactly what how we've done
that gone out
to really address people's genuine
concerns
and have open two-way conversations
about these vaccines and how safe they
are and how important they are to saving
lives and because we've worked with
local communities
on the design of the vaccination program
so we can deliver it
in a way that works for people in a
place they trust by
people they trust our vaccination
program has been
delivered in the community by the
community and for
the community and it's been a brilliant
brilliant
experience to see vaccinations being
given in churches synagogues gudoras
mosques temples and many other pillars
of the community
all across the whole of the united
kingdom and to see the determined
effort of the brilliant people
real partners on the ground to reach
communities where
take-up has been lower this concerted
community-led
effort i believe has truly paid off and
we're seeing
real positive results so if you look at
the latest data from the office for
national statistics the ons
vaccine hesitancy has halved in the past
few months among
black and black british people since
february and it's halved among asian
and asian british people two in the same
period this is real progress
but we know there's more much more to do
as we look to tackle and take on those
final steps those hard yards
on the road to recovery we need to make
sure
as many people are protected as possible
so we're intensifying doubling down our
efforts
to get more people to come forward and
we're seeing real results
in places like bolton and of course in
the northwest
and elsewhere we're honing on areas
where uptake is lower for example in
london
where the percentage of first doses is
slightly behind
the other areas in the united kingdom
the london team is doing
an incredible job and i can confirm
today that we're supporting them we're
supporting them with a london
summit that will take place on friday
bringing together senior officials
the nhs in london the mayor of london
clinical experts and community leaders
from across the capital
so that we can see what has worked and
how we can learn from it and
scale it and of course focus on how we
make sure we really do boost
that crucial uptake in the crucial few
weeks before the 19th
of july thanks to our vaccination
program our incredible nhs
this country is getting a little bit
safer
every day whatever your age
whatever your background the vaccine
will protect you it'll protect your
family and
all the people that you care about so
please come forward
and get both doses
so we can take that final step on the
road
to recovery